the u.s and russia are finally in
agreement over syria
after a two and a half year deadlock the
two countries drew up a draft resolution
regarding the use of chemical weapons
the draft decisions that are being
submitted to the organization for the
prohibition of chemical weapons
we have also agreed upon a russian
american draft resolution which will be
submitted to the security council today
with a draft now in place the u.n
security council could vote on the
resolution as early as friday evening
thank you it's our hope that that
process between the organization for the
prevention of chemical weapons
and the united nations and its
resolution
can now move forward and give life
hopefully
uh to the removal and destruction of
chemical weapons from syria
the resolution obliges the syrian
government to give up its chemical
weapons arsenal
but it doesn't apportion blame for the
chemical attack that killed 1400 people
in august
and it doesn't include automatic
consequences should syria fail to comply
in that case the security council would
have to vote on a second resolution that
would give syrian president bashar
al-assad's allies another chance to veto
further action
but for now a political solution to the
war in syria appears to have moved a
step closer